a special pop in here
so let's let's go let's go to the po poc
poppin
mr popock how are you
the po pog poppin i feel like the poppin
fresh kid from uh
pillsbury doughboy oh oh okay you know
yeah how are you it's been it's been a
minute it's been a minute but i'm glad
you're back wait a minute can you hear
me how's my mic you're always adjusting
my mic for me how's it today no no no
it's it's perfect it's perfect i see i
see you're sitting in a position though
where there is no controversy of rather
that painting is crooked i can't i can't
tell you how much um
ink has been taken up
with the question of whether that blue
painting behind me when i sit at my desk
and i do the podcast for legal af is
crooked i get all these compliments
about the show great show tonight i
really like the show i love the
camaraderie between you and ben myself
but that painting is driving me crazy i
get it with this one here i get it see
how this kind of looks crooked yes it's
it's not crooked i checked it but the
camera makes it look crooked because of
you know
but but you know this is ali
did you see on my twitter feed that i
actually posted a picture of the
painting with a level on top of it with
the bubbles to show the first level
still still no one believes well you
know we we live we live in a skeptic
society today um the the craziest part
is is like what we're talking about just
before you came on is that people will
believe absolutely anything and really
we're in it we're primed we're primed
and ready to believe almost anything
because anything is possible when we
hear stories like i knew i did not have
the president united states ripping up
notes and eating them and then flushing
you know he was so full he ate four
boxes of top top secret documents that
he had to start flushing him down a
toilet i i can't even tell you like we
are in such a weird
timeline but but but i know you can
probably speak to
what the legality of this is because
last week we were talking about the
presidential records act right because
he may have taken stuff that he
shouldn't have that belonged to the
office of the president but now it's
switched a little bit
because now we're talking about
did he or did he not take top secret
documents because that's a whole nother
realm of legality and what it means when
you're talking about taking documents
whether it's the presidential records
act or this top secret thing
and when it was when it was hillary
clinton and everybody was all upset that
she had a private email server in the
basement of chappaqua long island house
by the way
many many politicians have their own
servers the only the question there is a
nuance of public records law
and what what has to be secured she
didn't destroy anything it wasn't not
available to the national archive it
just happened for a time to be stored
because she was switching between
you know hillary.gov and hillary
personal and that things happened i'll
tell you what she didn't do she didn't
take 12 boxes of documents marked top
secret with her and imagine to get to 12
boxes tony
as the president and his people you got
to go through hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of thousands of boxes and
pieces of material and go these are the
12 that i want to take with you to
mar-a-lago
those are the hot 12.
you know
what do you think do you think he was
like collecting him throughout the four
years and he's like i'm definitely going
to take i'm definitely going to take
these at the
end outside do you think like it was a
mad dash at the end
when they make the tv movie about it it
will be what you just said which is he's
oh this box is definitely coming with me
tomorrow
but i don't in the real world of of
trump and his lunacy and his madness i
just think at the end you know somebody
knocked on the door and said mr
president yes so we've identified
another box that you probably would like
to take with you to mar-a-lago oh what's
in that box
what's in my box i want an inventory
it's the greatest box in the world i
love this right right right okay that
box is definitely going give it to
milani you could just see the whole by
the way that's about as close to trump
as i'm gonna get okay okay i don't do a
good trump either so it's okay yeah no
that's uh mine is sort of like alec
baldwin doing trump doing whatever but
okay um no i think that's how it went
and and the fact that he actually
highlighted how how important it was to
him that these documents not end up in
the national archive and not see the
light of day with the jan sex committee
ultimately because he knew going out
there was going to be a big problem so
he took these with him now
national archive has gone one step
further than they went with hillary
clinton
which is they think there's a possible
criminal
criminal obstruction criminal
violation of the records laws
and has made a referral to the
department of justice and the department
of justice merrick garland is going to
open up a uh investigative file and
determine what's in the boxes
why were they taken i mean what's trump
going to say i mean uh you have maggie
haber for the new york times who
apparently according to close confidants
of trump
that's the book that he's most worried
about not the
uh the uh you know the book bob woodward
wrote
you know a couple of books that bob
woodward wrote he's worried about maggie
haber because maggie haber an intrepid
new york times reporter for the last 20
or 30 years has been following trump
since like the day he bought the first
hotel with daddy's money
and and knows him better than anybody
else i mean there's actually a photo of
him with maggie haber maybe you can find
it while we're talking or put it up um
where he's got the you know it's got the
giant thumbs up or small thumbs up and
he's smiling with maggie haber in the
white house
she knows her [ __ ] she's an intrepid
investigative reporter this is where the
flushing the toilet came from an excerpt
from maggie haber he's worried about
more coming out of that book and so um
he's worried about it he takes these
boxes with him
national archive says
i don't have everything i need to do to
turn over to the jan 6 committee there's
12 boxes missing the interesting thing
and we have to get to the bottom of is
why did it take the the national archive
and the national archivist a person why
did it take them this long to determine
that there were boxes that were missing
like what was what tipped them off to
that you know they don't sound like that
video of 12 boxes going out something
tipped them off now maybe the jan six
committee work tipped them off
uh about the missing boxes
well
that that that that's a really good
point and and again that's how the story
has evolved right like at first it was
he had the kim jong-un letters right and
he had and he had the the poster board
with the sharpie on it where he was
trying to convince people that no no no
this map really you remember sharpie or
in this in this set of you know [ __ ]
that he took and he also had he also had
the kim jong-un letters which the story
is is that oh he's still talking to him
and he's still communicating with him
you know they still had this bromance
going on but so it's evolved into that
but it's evolved all the way down to
this guy's taking top secret documents
and not only that he's eating he's
eating he's eating documents and he's
flushing them down the toilet where is
the eating flushing i know the flushing
where's the eating part so
who's reporting on that i'm omarosa and
and
i i would love to have michael cohen on
my show omarosa claims in her book
that she watched donald trump put
documents in his mouth notes from a
meeting that he had with michael cohen
he was she watched him eat these notes
i don't know
you know
now i mean i guess i guess
if you're in a situation where you're in
a room and you're talking about
sensitive stuff and there's notes that
are going to prove that there's a crime
been committed possibly and the only way
to make sure that that document doesn't
see the light of day when you exit that
room is to rip it up and eat it i mean i
guess maybe that's your thought process
that's that's some crazy [ __ ] i'm not
listen uh i'm gonna believe maggie
haber's reporting over amarosa
she's got a road she has her own
credibility problems i think it's you
know he look he's mad as a hatter um
donald trump
i'm just not ready to buy into the um to
the eating and crapping part but from a
legal standpoint which is where legal af
comes in and we'll be talking about this
more on our weekend podcast that then my
salas and i do uh live saturday nights
and
and drop the audio on sunday uh sunday
mornings we're going to talk about
you know the presidential records act
criminal prosecutions related to this
inner you know um obstruction of justice
and other counts that could be brought
against
against the president and when he's on
the way out
he no longer enjoys immunity
so anything he did as citizen trump
with the moving trucks on the day out on
the day of or the switchover from the by
you know the trump administration at
1201 when biden takes the oath of office
he is now citizen trump and he doesn't
get immunity there's no there's no i've
been i was president five minutes ago
immunity defense for the 12 boxes he can
be prosecuted for that now um what will
he be we'll have to see but look the gen
6 committee is now
rapidly coming to a conclusion
of its work and it's
i think in the next month if not earlier
they're going to be doing televised
hearings in which they present
a lot of video and audio evidence and
documentary evidence on a powerpoint for
the american people led probably if i
had a guest by jamie raskin and a couple
of the other um you know really eloquent
legal scholars that are on the gen 6
committee and um
yeah i think
i think there's there's going to be a
lot of offshoots coming off of that with
criminal referrals the department of
justice from the gen 6 committee one and
that's a good point because um
all the evidence are are the top secret
documents in these 15 boxes or whatever
it was that the national archives had to
go down and you know rumman's through an
old dusty attic and a
beat-up golf club down in south florida
um the reason why the reason the reason
why that's significant is because those
documents are possibly in the hands of
the january 6th select committee and
and
whatever those documents are rather
there's criminal activity because this
guy is not going to stop criming um
rather there's criminal activity of him
taking them but if there's criminal
activity inside those documents that's
the important thing that the january 6th
select yeah
yeah we have to guess it's not 12 boxes
of telephone books he picked these boxes
for a reason you know this could be the
mother lode you know back in the
watergate era which we talked about a
lot
when we talked about trump and what
happened to those
culprits
uh including attorney generals going to
jail uh you know mitchell went going to
jail jerry watergate you know there's
the famous story of the uh 18 missing
minutes
from uh audio tapes that nixon ran
you know there was an early rudimentary
recording system in the white house
which really there should still be now
and there there was 18 minutes missing
at a critical moment that would have um
that would have uh implicated uh nixon
you know and then you have people trying
to cover for him like his secretary who
said oh i accidentally erased my foot my
foot pedal
like you know
it happens right happens this is 12
boxes of material that he was trying to
delete that he's trying to delete his
injury it hasn't come out in the
reporting yet but i got to believe the
jan six committee tipped them off the
national archives because how would they
have known there were 12 boxes missing
you know when you get the inventory it's
not like you go hmm you know you're
doing the inventory and you're like
you sound like they had a checklist like
where's where's box six six through you
know 18 right where are they seem to be
missing somebody must have said boxes
went out the back door and how did they
get to 12. i really want to find out the
reporting here on how they who who
dropped the dime on trump and how how
are they so specific in their
information
right well again you know it's probably
this is the most fantastic box ever and
i have to have this box you know that
that may have been you know because the
information inside would be
fantastically um the ability to probably
indict him for more crimes because i
don't bla
like you're saying i don't believe he
took these boxes because he has some
kind of you know a connection to these
documents
he's taking these documents for a reason
have you ever seen pictures of trump
like in his office he's got like just
like stacks of of paper and it's a mess
it's a mess right it's a mess
and and you know that that's probably a
lot what this is is the big mess that
he's stuffing inside boxes because he's
like i have to keep these i have to keep
these because i i don't want anyone to
see this stuff and back to the uh
the deleting of the the nixon tapes the
other news that we had was that there
was deleting of phone records inside the
white house that they haven't found yet
of communications on the day of the
january 6 um the insurrection
the coup attempt and i think that's
going to be a significant thing when
they figure that out too um as well that
was
well a couple of things one is to
correct ourselves it looks like it's 15
boxes that we're taking yeah yeah um
yeah now by the way trump might have
actually you know somebody on his staff
might have found him at mar-a-lago and
said
uh
these aren't supposed to be here these
are radioactive they're supposed to go
back to the network right right right
because apparently they've already
recovered them and they've looked inside
of those boxes including the north
korean memorabilia that you talked about
but on the
missing phone logs i'm not sure that
that may not fall into the category of
the missing 18 minutes on the on the
nixon tapes that may just be that he
stayed off the phone
during critical moments and to and or
directed traffic in other ways so
they're going to have to get us text
they're going to have to get so so what
you're saying is is that there's not a
phone record but there's possibly a
record someplace else and that may be
where they find it would anybody be
surprised that he used the communication
device and didn't have it properly
logged does that does that surprisingly
i mean you know or he was doing it
through you know he's on his own
personal phone he gets rudy giuliani in
the war room or flynn in the war room at
the hotel across the street on the phone
and he says all right boys what's
happening okay green light or whatever
he says but it but again it hurts the
gen 6's ability to connect the dots
and and place trump
at the at the arranging and organizing
leading into jan six
um because now they're gonna have to
rely on the eyewitnesses like you know
melania's
uh pr person who said he was in the
dining room enjoying lunch
you know and being really happy about
watching everybody on television storm
the capitol
they may never get
all of the dots connected between
between the two of them but there's
there's such powerful
circumstantial which is not a bad thing
in the law people think oh it's
circumstantial most cases are proved
through circumstantial evidence but just
the overwhelming quantity and quality of
the circumstantial evidence leads to the
inference the legal inference
logical inference that that that night
followed day that the moon follows the
sun
you may not see it
you know but but you know it's there i
mean i i don't see the moon impacting
the tides
but i know they are right so right we we
get all that together and that's what
the jan six committee's gonna do even if
this is missing i don't want people to
think oh no they'll never be able to
connect trump to this there's missing
phone locks there's enough witness
testimony documented documentary
testimony from cooperating witnesses
even ones i believe who have gone on on
the media because they don't want to
risk the ire of trump and have said
we'll never cooperate over my dead body
bernie carrick you know uh mccallahan
whatever the press secretary's name is
uh the the woman that was um fox news
mac and ninny whatever her name is
they've all gone in and testified by the
way right right right
and they totally played the fifth on all
of it they didn't say a word yeah right
i don't think so i mean even even stuart
rhodes from a jailhouse cooperated with
the jan six committee and while he did
assert the fifth amendment where frankly
he should have because he is i mean
the likelihood of criminal prosecution
is beyond a likelihood he's being
criminally prosecuted so he shouldn't
have to testify against himself but
apparently because of his ego and
otherwise he decided there were some
things he could tell the gen 6 committee
so even stuart rhodes is you know
testified right well that's a good point
because
i interviewed
tasha adams his strange ex-wife and his
estranged son um and that interviews on
youtube and it's fascinating um but when
you go look at that six hours of
testimony the story is is that he he
didn't testify on anything from january
5th and january 6th so the lead up to
the insurrection which leads me to
believe that um possibly and the gen 6
committee was like yep sure but i want
to ask you as maybe a federal criminal
defense attorney
is that significant in the in the
criminal um indictment that he has that
that gen 6 wouldn't maybe want him to
actually um you know testify or say a
few things that would damage the
possibility of the federal prosecutors
bringing that indictment against him on
the conspiracy charges and possibly
roping more people into the conspiracy
because that's what happens with a
federal prosecution when they indict
conspiracy is there superseding
indictments with that conspiracy that
continue to draw in more fish as they
say you know little fish big fish stuff
to draw in more fish to this indictment
but do you think that had anything to do
with the gen 6 committee saying okay
we'll let you come in and and and
give your testimony but we will leave
out the january 5th january 6th
no
i don't think so and the reporting is
they left off the january 5th of january
so the reporting the reporting is that
that the select committee um they wanted
that of course but stewart rhodes and
his attorneys did not take the uh they
they waved
to actually give the january 5th and
january 6 testimony of those days well
they can't they can't he's facing
criminal prosecution right well and they
and they won't they they can in january
6 the select committee but in the
criminal prosecution there's no waiving
anything i mean it's a full-on discovery
right yeah so so there's nothing that
they can do there um i i just wanted to
know if there's significance in that
waving i don't think so
okay no i i don't think so i think you
know i think the new york times did it
for people that are interested the new
york times about two weeks ago did a
very good double double centerfold
um
walking through
you know the first 10 oath keepers the
next 10 oath keepers who's been indicted
for conspiracy who's been indicted for
obstruction and why and a timeline
starting three months you know really
like the day after the election leading
into jan you know two three four five
and then six and who did what you know
who who's the weapons officer you know
who brought in all the weapons and
stored them in the days in you know uh
for use you know who what did stuart
rhodes do and when when did the other
nine people that were indicted along
with him what did they do with him and
what did the others do and it's a very
good timeline date by date by date by
date so if i commend people to go look
at that if they're interested in seeing
why there's an indictment of these
people do you think do you think there's
a a conspiracy beyond the oath keepers
to
something maybe to this rolling stone
article that we've seen several months
ago where
members of congress possibly were were
bartering with pardons
for people to act on behalf of trump and
kind of connecting with trump through
channels um to promise pardons whether
that was you know the pardons were
actually gonna happen or not because he
stood on stage a couple weeks ago and he
said yep i'm going to pardon anyone
january 6th oh yeah right so he so my
guess is maybe obstruction in another
which may be obstruction in and of
itself just him saying it into a
microphone
well and so so my guess my question is
is is do you think there's with that
reporting with the members of congress
can that conspiracy from what you've
read about the oath keepers can it
continue to again little fish big fish
stuff
yeah it could i think i i'm gonna i'm
gonna uh keep my powder dry
yeah until the giant sex committee comes
in not taking any bets is what you're
saying
yeah i mean look if there were evidence
i just don't like to deal too much in
the in the world of speculation i like
to be more you know um
well
so i'd like to get the play-by-play
right you know that's a good point
though that the play by play because i
think that's a little bit of this drip
drip drip out of the select committee
and also what they'll try to orchestrate
through the
um when they do the actual public
hearings is try to tell the story of
what happened on january 6th and what
happened with the insurrection and and
how this was a coordinated effort to
overthrow the constitution and our vote
um i think they'll they'll kind of work
that in a way uh to make sure that that
story is told but they're not gonna i'd
be shocked they're not gonna pull any
punches during the presentation right
they're going to put up on the screen
the cawthrans of the world and all the
other house members
and marjorie taylor green and all the
people if they have evidence that some
of them held the door open or gave them
a tour the day before
and let them do a little map making uh
as a blueprint for the uh insurrection
that's going to go up on the screen for
people to know this this uh legislator
did this the day before in giving a tour
to these people this person encouraged
it this way this person incited the riot
this way and they're going to
distinguish because you know this will
answer the stupid question asked by
ronald daniels of the rnc
which is the whole thing is just
legitimate political
discourse let's break it okay let's make
let's make it simple
the [ __ ] on the ellipse
of a rally
as distasteful as those that follow your
show and my show may find it
is legitimate first amendment expression
and political discourse right and i welc
and i welcome it i really want to live
in a country where jack booted you know
you know uh gazpachos
came down the mall i mean cold soup cold
soup police came down there yeah yeah
he's the only person in the history of
the world that made the nazis sound
delicious
um so so we don't i don't want to live
in a jack-booted world where people
suppress first amendment expression so
what happened on the ellipse
proper legitimate political discourse
right the subgroup the subset of that
that were always as we know from the
proud boy investigation were always
there
to
uh wreak havoc
and try to overthrow the government and
the peaceful transfer of power they were
a subset of the group that was at the
ellipse some of them were at the ellipse
many of them skipped the speech making
at the ellipse and went directly to the
capitol
right to commit
chaos well there's this big venn diagram
right like right what you're saying
so so rhona daniels is mcdaniels is
right only about
the the group and there were you know
frankly there were peaceful people at
the ellipse i may not agree with them
politically but i don't care if they're
there listening to who they thought was
their president that's fine the subset
of violent
anarchists
this is what they are they're heroes
they're not patriots they were
anarchists
that wanted to
overthrow the country and stop the
peaceful transfer of power and the will
and frustrate the will of the people
that armed and dangerous
that armed insurrection that's not
legitimate political discourse
well no i well i mean i mean the the day
of january 6 to to try and and
pin it up as all legitimate political
discourse even mitch mcconnell batted
that down quickly and my thought is is
that mitch mcconnell does not
as much as we do not like his politics
he does not use an unmeasured word at
all in front of a microphone and for him
to come out and basically say
support mike pence and saying that trump
is a loser and what he did is
un-american and by doing that by
supporting that message you know through
the week um i i think they know stuff's
coming i think they know these public
hearings are not going to be good i
think i think they know
um
this news about
these documents as silly as some of it
may be
that it is real the oath keepers being
charged with seditious conspiracy is
real this is going to extend on um like
you said you're going to have members of
congress being called out right into
these hearings um i believe there could
be even be a list of expulsion um that
is brought to the floor because of some
of this evidence that is brought in
today i agree with these public hearings
so right whether that's rather that's
their direct aim or not um i think
that's a possibility so i appreciate you
joining us pope thanks thanks
come back anytime just send a message
whenever you're ready uh everyone stick
around right after this we're going to
do bonehead of the week you'll you'll
love this pobag the bone end of the week
um this week we've got we've got the
brian suave we got forrest gump kevin
mccarthy did you see him run run kevin
run did you see did you see that no but
i'll watch i'll follow up and watch your
show yeah and then jared kushner is also
on the list but we had some other people
that we had to add in like the uh the
soup nazi margaery taylor green so
everyone
go follow popock on twitter at ms popock
and go watch legal af this weekend it's
on saturdays on youtube live and then it
download you can download it on all your
your favorite directors on sundays well
we're on we we we're having fun you're
on there sometimes we do an 8 p.m
eastern time youtube live recording of
the podcast goes a couple hours you know
get get something comfortable go get a
six pack we go and i go through you know
eight to ten
cutting edge this week legal and
political stories from supreme court you
know this week i know i know we're
talking about we're gonna be talking
about the alabama decision on the voting
rights act and gerrymandering we're
going to talk about sarah palin's uh
lawsuit which is now in the first week
of trial for defamation against the new
york times here in in new york we're
talking about the first jan 6 trial
the first criminal trial where the
justice department to show its stuff and
shred its stuff and put up all of its
evidence it's gonna be happening at the
end the end of february and uh
and we're and we're gonna talk about
scotus and the and the decision that
scotus is uh that the biden
administration's gonna be making about
the next justice so we've got a lot to
talk about join us there and then we
drop it on you know
apple pod and spotify and all that on
sunday morning at midnight and then you
do also a wednesday show so catch that
as well yeah we're doing a wednesday
show half an hour wednesdays with
another co-anchor karen uh friedman
agnifilo who used to be in cybance's
manhattan da's office and we talked it
kind of leans a little bit more
prosecutorial but we
we do that a drill down uh every
wednesday also on all those channels for
30 minutes tony thanks for having me
thank you thank you sir and
everyone stick around we'll be back with
the bonehead after this thanks for
joining us pope bach
thanks we'll see you soon
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Applause]
[Music]
under president joe biden the american
economy adds 467
000 new jobs in the month of january
thanks brandon
[Music]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking with us we're going
to do bone end of the week